Tommy has finally been released from
prison. He walked out after 7 months in
solitary confinement wearing a cross and
a rosary leading to some interesting
questions. Now, on the issue of solitary
confinement, I can speak from some
experience here since I've been to
prison. I was in solitary a few times in
jail, not because I was being punished,
but because of mental health issues. And
I can say that after you've been in
isolation for a while, you start acting
weird. I don't know exactly why this
happens. I'll give you my theory. Some
of you with a background in psychology
or neuroscience can share your thoughts
in the comments. My theory is that when
you're regularly interacting and
communicating with other people, a
certain part of your brain is active.
But when you're not interacting and
communicating with other people, that
part of your brain isn't active. And if
you spend enough time in isolation, that
part of your brain atrophies like a
muscle that doesn't get used. In other
words, imagine staying in bed and not
moving for 7 months and then getting out
of bed trying to walk around. Not going
to be easy because you haven't been
using your muscles. I think something
similar to that goes on with your brain.
You haven't been using part of your
brain, so it doesn't work as well when
you start interacting with people.
Again, if anyone knows what's really
going on, please explain. So, knowing
that solitary makes people act weird, I
was expecting Tommy to be pretty messed
up after 7 months in a cell by himself,
especially since he looked really messed
up when he got out of prison in 2018.
When he got out of prison in 2018, he
looked and sounded and acted like he had
PTSD. And in a new interview right after
he got out of prison a few days ago, he
talks about getting out of prison in
2018 and having to adjust to normal life
after spending a couple of months in
isolation. And the jumble, I was happy
even in there. Whilst I was whilst I
knew I was panicked because I knew the
long-term effect of solitary
confinement. I remember last time I was
in prison. I remember the problems I had
when I was released. So, constantly I
was concerned for that. It's probably
going to take me a little while to
readjust anyway. I remember last time I
had problems. I felt weird going back to
my house. I'd rather physically fight
every day. Yeah. Than have you be able
to mentally destroy me. Now, I figured
that if Tommy looked like he had PTSD in
2018 after spending two months in a
cell, he was obviously going to look
significantly worse this year after
spending 7 months in a cell. But apart
from sporting a hobo beard and looking
like the guy who always hits me up for
change at the gas station, he sounded
exactly like Tommy. 16 years ago when I
first started speaking out against
Islamic gangs that were plaguing this
country. From that point on I faced
relentless attacks from the British
state, wielding lawfare as a weapon in
order to silence me. Since the start of
my activism in 2009, police raids, court
cases, lawfare has been waged against
anyone who has challenged the globalist
narratives. Challenge open border
challenge mass immigration. You've seen
in my film how they silence people.
NDAs, bullying, intimidation, scare
tactics, and even attempts at prison.
There is a war being waged on Britain,
and it's being waged by our leaders, and
it's a war against free speech. Our
weapon is free speech. They can't allow
it. We want to hold a free speech
festival in London as a show of
defiance. It's going to be a festival of
free speech. It's going to be a day of
celebration. And the mass awakening has
happened. It continues to happen. We put
the fear of God into them when they saw
the way we united this country. when we
united people from everywhere to come
together. The 13th of September is going
to be the biggest date. Make your plans.
There's no excuses. Since I was
expecting him to sound at least somewhat
insane after 7 months in isolation, but
he didn't at all, I came up with two
theories. One, he received a ton of
letters and cards while he was in
prison. He came out with entire
cartloads of mail.
And that wasn't even all the mail Tommy
posted on X. Thank you to each and every
one of you who sent mail to me as I sat
in prison during the last 7 months. As
you can see, there was a lot. These
trolley loads were just what was left.
Eight sacks had already been sent out.
Yet, I read every single word, and it
means more than you'll ever know.
laughing, crying, learning. The support
of you, the people helped me through the
darkest days. Thank you. Hats off to
everyone who sent him cards and letters.
Seems like it played a huge role in
helping him maintain his sanity. My
second theory about how he handled these
seven months in isolation so much better
than he handled two months in isolation
back in 2018 had something to do with
the cross he came out wearing. We'll
discuss that after a brief word from
this video's sponsor. Suppose you get
out of prison after spending 7 months in
solitary confinement. Getting things in
the mail and reading the Bible have
somehow kept you from losing your mind.
But you need to adjust back to life in
the outside world. What do you do? Don't
worry. Artsa has you covered. Since you
love getting things in the mail, imagine
getting a box full of handpicked
treasures from the places where Jesus
walked. Items from Jerusalem and
Nazareth and Bethlehem delivered to your
door. I'm talking about getting an Artza
box. Every Artza box connects you with
the Bible and is filled with items that
will bless your home. And by signing up,
you'll be supporting the local Christian
and Jewish families and businesses and
charities that create them. You get
candles, Israeli spice mixes, olive wood
carvings, mosaic art, decorations,
cosmetics, candy, games, all kinds of
things. And the recipes in the booklet
will help you forget all about the gr
sandwiches and grl omelets you've been
eating in prison. Arts of boxes are fun
to open with your family, and they make
great gifts. There's a new box every
season, four new boxes every year. So,
join Artza and bring the Holy Land into
your home one season at a time. The link
is in the description. Use the promo
code Dizzle to get a discount and to let
them know who sent you. Now, back to the
cross hanging from Tommy's neck. I
wouldn't have thought too much of it.
Lots of people wear crosses as jewelry
or just out of habit, but someone sent
me to 2CTV's new video where I saw this.
A lot of people have already heard the
news anyway. But one of the good things
that happened during this uh evil
torture treatment that he went through,
apart from all the bad things that
happened to him, including that crazy
beard, is his full conversion to
Christianity. That's interesting. For
years, I thought that Tommy was an
atheist or an agnostic. I don't recall
where I got that idea, but that's what I
thought. So, when someone brought up
Tommy's cross during a recent live
stream, I asked people in the chat about
what Tommy believed, and most people
said he was an atheist, but I can't
think of where I got that idea. So, let
me know if there's some video or
interview where Tommy shared his
beliefs. But whatever Tommy believed in
the past, he did come out of prison
wearing a cross. And Mahar Tusi says
that Tommy became a Christian in prison.
I don't know if Tusi just saw Tommy's
cross and rosary and jumped to a
conclusion, but Tusi knows Tommy, so he
probably knows what he's talking about.
Why could this be important news? Well,
many of us are convinced that the only
hope for the UK and the only hope for
Europe is some sort of revival. I've
been saying for a while that 2025 is a
really good year for a really big
change. Apostasy rates in Islam have
been skyrocketing and the new atheism
has lost its
momentum. Young people are abandoning
atheism and church attendance is
increasing. Some people think it's too
late for Europe. And you can look around
and see why they think that, but you
should also look at the signs of a
spiritual and moral
awakening. And there are signs
everywhere. That's about all I know from
the videos that came out over the past
few days. If you've heard something else
or if you've seen something I've missed,
please share it in the comments.
[Music]